and so i'm watching this and i don't
really understand much of it but again
it's part of getting into the atmosphere
the culture the mood of the language hi
there steve kaufman here
my first week of my 90-day challenge how
has your first week been in your 90 day
challenge
as i said i'm trying to maintain a
streak in two languages arabic and
persian and i'm also focusing on those
two languages to some extent
so i want to every week sort of do a
video where i talk about how my week
went
hopefully that's of interest and
relevant to
whatever you're doing don't forget to
click on the bell if you would like to
subscribe and get notifications
so
the 90-day challenge began officially on
june the first
uh i came back to vancouver
the evening of the 28th
of may
and of course we're in quarantine
my wife and i
and the following their various
protocols we get
emails daily we've even had a phone call
to check on us to make sure we're in
quarantine
um
eight we had to do our
test again we were online zoom
conferencing with a nurse
who
took us through our steps and we put our
test samples in a little bag and
notified the pure later the courier
service so they could come and pick it
up we left it in our mailbox
so those kinds of things
and so you know i think any one of us
who's in a 90-day challenge we have
other things happening in our lives
in our case for example
we went down to california a because
it's warmer down there but primarily
because we had mass major renovations in
our house
drywall dust and floors being sanded and
this kind of thing and we wanted to get
away from this
in order for that renovation to take
place we had to move all kinds of stuff
into a few rooms and now we're going
back in there and gradually putting
things back and then trying to figure
out what really we shouldn't keep
because we've got
you know things that we've had for 50
years and all of this is very time
consuming i'm able to do a lot of it
while listening to arabic or persian
however you can't do all of it that way
because sometimes you do have to focus
and i have to interact with my wife and
that sort of thing so
essentially what i've done the first
week is i said week one is going to be
arabic
and um i want to get into as i've said
sort of egyptian arabic fortunately my
tutor for standard arabic muhammad is
from cairo he's an excellent tutor and
of course he obviously speaks egyptian
so we have been doing some egyptian i've
now had two sessions where i read the
egyptian mini stories and then we
uh he asked me questions and i answer
and so
this is very effective actually in terms
of getting me into saying things in
egyptian understanding egyptian and i am
finding that
exploring the regional variance the
spoken variance of arabic is very
helpful because very often the political
podcast that i listened to we'll have
someone on there whose standard arabic
is very much influenced by levantine or
egyptian arabic and both levantine and
egyptian arabic are closer to each other
than they are to standard arabic so it's
all good all right
now
because i'm not going to write a test on
my arabic and i'm quite content to let
it you know
put along i progress as much as i
progress
um
so it's easy for me to get distracted so
and it's this has happened before my
wife likes to watch films on netflix
series
um
usually in foreign languages and very
often that will attract me to a language
so she started watching this thing
called the
body hotel it or seaside hotel in danish
and i you know i can't help it first of
all it's a fun show really a lot of fun
and i like the scenery in northern new
land and denmark
it's silly of course like all these
series are but but the great thing about
these netflix series is that you kind of
get together in the evening with your
friends or so it seems
the people in this show they're forever
having dinner and talking in the same
group of people are meeting and and so i
i joined them it's like joining a group
of friends every evening so it is a lot
of fun i like listening to danish so i
said geez i got to get better at danish
because there's a lot of words in danish
that are not like swedish
here and there so you kind of get the
gist but you miss a lot so i went into
my mini stories in danish
uh at link
and discovered that uh if i remember
correctly kuhn is a woman
i guess that's quina kun and con is only
i think and there's a whole bunch of
rather key little words like that that
are quite different in danish than they
are in swedish so i went through
listening to 25 mini-stories discovered
that we only have 25 so i'm hoping we
can get the rest of them done
i think we should get all the mini
stores completed at link in those
languages where they aren't complete but
it's also an example of how
we have to enjoy what we're doing and
and if along the way while i'm doing my
arabic i'm attracted by danish or as
happened with turkish i'm doing arabic
and persian and then my wife is watching
a turkish series so i go in and learn a
little bit of turkish and i'll probably
do that again at some point
so that's kind of the way my week's been
going
and typically i'll get on my stepper and
listen to one of my arabic
contents if if it's arabic week
and then i said to myself
you know where i have my stepper we
actually have another tv so i said geez
i'm going to see if i can find
a movie in egyptian arabic and
i found this
movie called asma it's about a woman in
egypt who
very complicated story but has aids and
encounters difficulties and it's a great
movie
and so i'm watching this and i don't
really understand much of it but again
it's part of getting into the atmosphere
the culture the mood of the language so
i'm continuing to you know i've set
myself rather minimal goals i want to go
13
i want to create 13 links a day
and i'm doing it to get up and get
started on that in arabic and persian in
arabic it's not difficult to do because
i just have to go on to youtube or
somewhere find something
um
you know franz netcat interview
uh
captured you know the url put it on this
website i have
youtube to mp3 download the mp3 file
take the mp3 file over to happy transcri
happy scribe i get the transcript i
import that as a lesson and in arabic
there's always lots of words blue words
it's more difficult to do that in
persian because there isn't so much
stuff available on youtube in persian
um
and in persian for whatever reason there
are fewer blue words like arabic has so
many words there's always words like it
full of yellow words now that i don't
know whereas in persian there are fewer
of them i don't know why that is it just
seems like arabic has a lot more words
anyway so i i quickly get to my 13 links
created although
today i've gotten sort of i've got
30 links created for error because i get
into an article and very quickly i'm
creating these links whereas in person i
haven't yet started today so my persian
is lagging behind i see that on the sort
of street with steve uh challenge i'm
like uh my ranked
1560 or something uh i'm not very high
up because there are people who are you
know
working harder in my case i have to have
a streak i'm not sure how the system
works because i'm doing two languages
but i've set a rather low level a low
bar so to that extent i'm keeping up
with my goal
but
the main thing about the sort of making
sure i get my 13
links created every day is that it just
it just triggers me it starts me off
okay
and next week i'm going to do more
persian i'm going to have
conversations with sarah i'm going to do
more persian content but still keep the
you know burner going on arabic so that
i don't slip too far behind
and that's kind of my situation that's
what i'm doing and we'll see how the
next week goes
and i'm curious to know how everyone
else's
challenge is proceeding bye for now